I accidentally became a meme and this is
that story it's weird to be famous as a
baby there were there wasn't really a
before really my whole life has been me
being success kid this all started in
2000 we went to the beach because I had
just gotten a new camera and they wanted
to take some pictures of my baby and my
family Sam was 11 months old he was
about to eat the handful of sand like
babies do and I just not the shot just
the right moment I thought it was a
really cute picture I had no idea how
profoundly it would impact our lives I
posted the picture to my Flickr account
the same day I took it it was
immediately popular and got about 300
likes the first day but then after that
I kind of forgot about it within a year
I started to see it online there's a
Photoshop child in the background with a
destroyed sandcastle and it had the
caption I hate sandcastles and there was
another version with the caption I'm a
we really had no idea what memes were
because they were so new but the ones
that did exist usually we're either
making fun of somebody or had negative
connotations we didn't want that to be
associated with our baby my picture was
just out there for anyone to
taken manipulate I realized at that
point there was no getting this picture
back the internet had it and then about
a year after that what's the first time
I saw it used with the green blue little
background my baby there was a title
success kid and when I saw that I
thought please let this person take off
it was so positive and sweet the great
thing about the success kid mean is that
not only is it about success but it's
about unlikely success achieving and
that was really special because Sam was
born prematurely then had to have brain
surgery at six weeks old so seeing it
called success kid just like for my
heart you know it's just I felt like
that was the most appropriate title for
him and it was given to him by the
internet before long we saw the picture
everywhere so all of the internet
advertising a Super Bowl commercial
Obama's White House around the world it
was something positive that was out
there that people really responded to
it's kind of hard to comprehend it's
weird being a famous baby because I had
no idea what was happening you know
that's a I do have a lot of mixed
feelings with it I would go back and
forth with being like I wish I was a
normal kid oh this is like you know this
is super awesome and so to have fans
come up to me we'd be like hey do the
pose or you know like what it's a
imitates like or whatever I'm like I
know and I I would say like candy or
something you know because like in my
mind I'm just a normal lazy teenager
usually just doing art and listening
music I've been doing art for I mean my
whole life really my dad has been a big
part of why I started
got that interest from him and you know
I would look at his art and you know
constantly copy it and stuff and then I
would gain a certain style you know
interest change and your mindset in your
body you know changes a lot and you
don't just want to be known as success
kid but then I found out that my dad was
sick I was diagnosed with chronic kidney
disease I had about 20% kidney function
when they caught it I was on dialysis
for six years really needed a kidney
transplant but I couldn't qualify
because the cost of the D rejection
drugs are so enormous you know for so
many people it's almost impossible we
just had the idea to do a fundraiser I
didn't want to mention success kid I
mean I wasn't even thinking about that
initially then I posted it on my Twitter
account some publications who retweeted
it and within the first week of the
GoFundMe being posted we surpassed our
goal we got so many messages saying how
much the mean is meant to them and how
much it brightens our day to see his
face or how they're going through a dark
time and so the best part of the
campaign really is just feeling like
we're getting this you know giant hug
from the world am very thankful for
everybody who has you know helped us and
everybody who uses the picture a lot of
nurses and doctors use it to get through
the day I'm very happy that you know
people who save others lives is using my
picture when I was doing nothing but
eating sand you know like it's a good
thought you know it's it helps me I'm at
an edge right now to where I don't
really know what
fully I do hope one day that I'll be
able to create something that inspires
people just as much as success kid does
[Music]
you